E aí
Olá este é o meu filho maneiro Então faz
hoje três anos
é realmente é
e ele é o menino mais doce que eu
conheço e
a gosto muito dela
a seguir ela há cerca de três meses
atrás veio a Índia
e eu também um bebê é bonzinho não dá
trabalho nenhum tá sempre a sorrir para
toda a gente e para imaginar os avós e
as mãe EA família é toda de babados
antes deles
veio ai é seis anos
quer ser inventor
Bom dia Lucas tem 4 anos adorando a
bicicleta
o Sr cap é minha namorada
Nórdica loira de olhos azuis é melhor
mãe do mundo e é minha melhor amiga
é a minha vida é perfeita
Oi mãe
é
a minha vida é uma colaboração é uma
colaboração onde estamos constantemente
em aprendizagem E acima de tudo
partilhamos uma visão um objetivo na
nossa vida
e para vocês perceberam bocadinho a de
que eu estou a falar é uma palavra que
se uma colaboração
vou ajudar vou falar de três casos e
vamos falar de uma colaboração que é uma
das colaborações mais em compreendidas
que é do casal e para estudar os três
cenários
o primeiro cenário
Esse é o cenário mais tradicional que
vocês estão habituados se calhar vem nos
vossos pais
em que um dos membros da família
trabalha trabalho ou seja tem emprego e
traz o dinheiro para casa e acaba por
mandar ou seja o homem da casa Amanda
e é uma situação muito simples
mas completamente injusta
G1
é um outro formato de casal
mais atual
a alma completa divisão de tudo das
responsabilidades das contas
da vida
é mais justo mas não há tempo para nada
que nós queremos fazer tudo
e esse formato se calhar Há muitos de
vocês vão ver e é para mim a evolução
que podia ser essa colaboração de casal
basicamente As pessoas olham para um fim
em comum ou seja um projeto em conjunto
dividem as tarefas mesmas mais ingratas
a
o fazem também
trabalham ou seja estas tarefas não não
alteram em nada o seu médico dentro da
família ou seja por eu ter um emprego
traz minha para casa ou passar o diabo
do Marco em casa a tomar conta dos
filhos não traz mais mérito ou não me
sobe na hierarquia por isso eu não mando
mais
com a colaboração para mim é aquele que
eu me propus a trabalhar
e para ir para os canto para continuar
este este processo do que eu comecei a
explicar vamos passar
aquelas ideias anteriores para um
formato ainda mais complexo que é a
questão das empresas Ou os grupos de
trabalho
e este é o formato tradicional das
empresas pós-revolução industrial
em que a divisão é completamente igual a
nível de responsabilidades benefícios e
mas é muito simples toda a gente tava
que tem que fazer
e quando não sabem alguém vem cá e disse
numa situação mais igualitária divisão é
aquilo que você já ouviram falar hoje de
estar tabs dois tipos de começam dividem
tudo é mais igual
e não é bem mais igual mas a idade não a
divisão a multiplicação a multiplicação
de tarefas motivo que multiplicação
responsabilidades e dar mais trabalho no
entanto estas empresas geralmente são
pequenas são muito ágeis E essas pessoas
tão propensa a por muitas horas no
trabalho que é por isso que isso resulta
em
E essas no entanto descobrimos uma forma
eficaz
bom então para crescermos basta dividir
ou multiplicar
a situação em que chegamos a um ponto em
que não é sustentável crescimento e as
empresas não podem ser mais que aquilo
então Voltamos ao início
bom e este ciclo que que acontece
normalmente
no entanto algumas empresas descobriram
uma configuração um mais complexa que a
olhar olho a olho desarmado não se
parece com nada
e é uma uma
uma estrutura não hierárquica não
aumente se baseado em médico cada um é
livre de escolher as trevas que quer
fazer
e assim falar parece que não existe no
entanto deixes aqui dois exemplos
as duas empresas uma delas chama-se
sempre com uma empresa brasileira nos
anos 70 revolucionou a forma como
trabalhava graças ao Ricardo semler e
outra empresa mais atual sistema sapos
que é uma empresa de
venda de artigos esportivos online que o
que é mais importante é cultura trabalho
e famosa por isso mas eu não ficar para
falar destas empresas nem muito menos
de empresas assim mas desses dois livres
para continuar para quem não os conhece
a lerem é homérico Ricardo Summer e o
livrinho apenas com o Tom e Jerry vale a
pena DF
há alguns anos atrás e depois de muitos
anos a trabalhar como designer
freelancer eu pus numa
comecei a detectar em mim uma uma um
Fascínio por esta coisa das pessoas
trabalharem em conjunto
eu gostava de saber como é que esta
coisa do do da colaboração funciona ou
não funciona
bom então eu e um amigo meu propusemos a
fazer um evento
durante 24 horas estaremos online
disponíveis para conversas e entrevistas
trabalhar alguns projetos e isto
aconteceu no dia 11/11
a e nesse E durante esse dia esse dia
essas 24 horas começou à meia-noite um
dia acabou na minha do outro dia
passaram por nós 177 pessoas de 19
países diferentes falamos de vários
projetos criou-se uma comunidade à volta
deste evento e essa comunidade cria um
grupo de discussão que durante um ano
mais ou menos começou a continuar a
discussão graças a esse evento e
E aí como uma das das grandes os grandes
temas era sempre a coloração como é que
nós poderíamos trabalhar melhor uns com
os outros e
e daí surge uma ideia de criar uma
plataforma colaborativa em que em que se
permite se
desenvolver projetos de uma forma mais
eficiente e
os dois desse grupo eu incluído
resolvemos começar uma fase lactato
durante seis meses em que nos vimos
dedicará a tentar desenvolver os
projetos até ao ponto
descobrimos tem que tinha tinha pernas
para andar e escolhemos vir para
Portugal tradições mas àquela altura
estava na Finlândia
esse período de seis meses
transformou-se em dois anos nunca mais
nos fundos embora isto aconteceu porque
quando chegamos à Óbidos
que uma fomos para ovos não foi ao
calhas eu vivi uma grande parte da minha
vida lá enquanto jovem
apresentaram nos um espaço em que nos
disseram tem que nos propuseram pensar
como é que podemos dizer espaço e a
nossa ideia inicial do Da Da forma
coletiva tinha a longo prazo uma ideia
de criar espaços com
Olá nestes grupos colaborativos poderiam
trabalhar
mas isto é no futuro só que ao nos
propormos essa ideia é
E aí e nós decidimos
reverter ao inverter a o processo e
começar pelo espaço foi a melhor coisa
que nós fizemos graças a isso
descobrimos coisas de outra forma não
queríamos saber conhecer as pessoas que
era impossível a conhecer tivemos
problemas que nunca que de outra forma
não ias ter
ah
e também fizemos coisas
muito interessantes
o colar é um laboratório para para
trabalharmos em conjunto é um
laboratório para desenvolvermos melhor
forma de trabalhar em conjunto E para
criar um modelo de colaboração pode ser
replicado em qualquer lugar
Em Chamas collab algumas você se calhar
já ouviram isto a falar meu colar bem
Óbidos
e o colab Óbidos a criou uma comunidade
um grupo e dizer evoluiu numa numa numa
direção em que se criou o modelo de
grupos colaborativos que foram se
desenvolvendo ao longo do tempo e que
passou a ser replicados de outras áreas
neste momento existem seis grupos ativos
colar existem oito espaços aderentes e
uma meia dúzia de outros projetos que se
que estão propostos lançar objetos
dentro do colab nós partilhamos acima
tudo o processo de trabalho também
partilhamos passo partilhar os recursos
para criar umas ideias partilhamos a
autoria EA
e
partilhamos um é mais do que que é mais
difícil de partilhar no nosso dia a dia
que a sermos donos todos das ideias de
todos esses permite-nos trabalhar de uma
forma mais eficiente permite-nos e nós
desenvolver projetos de outra forma que
só sozinhos não era capaz de fazer somos
capazes também de aprender mais em um
curto espaço de tempo
permitimos trabalhar com pessoas
diferentes que de outra forma é difícil
e que normalmente
tendemos a escolher sempre as pessoas as
mesmas pessoas para trabalhar ao pé de
nós as pessoas com que nos identificamos
permite resolver algumas destas questões
da colaboração
e
o produto deste processo São pessoas que
desenvolvem
eu
apertar Nato produtos design
campanhas de ativação
de campanhas felicidade e até empresas
é
destas pessoas que existem a questão que
existe neste momento existem de os tais
grupos em Lisboa em Óbidos dois grupos
em tela em marvão e um início na
Finlândia
estão a trabalhar em conjunto para criar
uma melhor forma trabalhar
E aí chamamos de colabo
e
o clube é um conceito para grupos
colaborativos que se propõe a
desenvolver a
uma
até a desenvolver um processo de
trabalho mais mais eficiente e permite a
todos desenvolverem seus projetos
com mais segurança com mais facilidade e
de certa forma também não estar tão
dependente daquilo que nós chamamos os
recursos
da sociedade e que numa situação
de escassez temos tendência a pensar que
se torna impossível ao mas quando
trabalhamos em conjunto conseguimos
fazer
o meu dia a dia
quero ver com o colar cada vez motor
melhor resolver os problemas e cada vez
me identifico mais com as pessoas que eu
trabalho e todos os dias em torno melhor
este processo torna-se melhor e partilhe
este processo com outras pessoas
bom e é com estas pessoas que eu faço
ideias peço obrigado a
E aí